Also ich habe... Ja, also dass das ein bisschen komisch aussieht, das Bein, das habe ich schon gemerkt.
Und es fühlt sich auch... Also die Haut ist ein bisschen anders als sonst.
Also nicht unbedingt die Farbe, aber die ist so ein bisschen schuppig.
Und was ich auch gemerkt habe, dass es manchmal so kribbelt im Unterschenkel.
Und Haarverlust? Ist Ihnen aufgefallen Haarverlust?
Das stimmt, das habe ich gemerkt, dass mir die Haare da auswirken. Ich dachte das hängt mit dem Alter zusammen.
Aber im Vergleich, im anderen Seite, ich meinte das...
Ja, stimmt, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Ist Ihnen ein Atemnot oder ein Atemnot, ein enger Gefühl aufgefallen?
Atemnot?
Ja genau.
Nö, also das wüsste ich nicht, deshalb habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Also ich könnte vom... Also da habe ich das Gefühl weiter laufen, aber die Beine tun halt weh, ne?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass meine linke Beine ein bisschen schuppig geworden sind.
Das Rechte?
Entschuldigung, das war recht. Und das Rechte war ein bisschen blass oder rötig?
Also die Farbe ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, weil mir ist halt aufgefallen, dass die Haut so schlecht ist.
Haut ist schlecht, ok.
Haben Sie auch nachts Wadenkrampfen oder irgendwas?
Oh ja, ja. Also manchmal habe ich nachts richtig schlechte Schmerzen.
Und das Komische ist, wenn ich dann so ein bisschen rumwander, dann geht's.
Dann wird es ein klein bisschen besser und dann kann ich mich auch wieder hinlegen.
Aber ich muss sowieso oft mal nachts zur Toilette, ein bis zwei Mal muss ich schon gehen.
Ja, aber deswegen habe ich eigentlich auch in der letzten Zeit nicht so gut geschlafen.
Treten diese Wadenkrampfen besonders vor allem nachts oder tagsüber?
Also tagsüber ist das nur beim Laufen.
Nur beim Laufen.
Aber in der Nacht habe ich schon auch manchmal diese Schmerzen.
Ist Ihnen ein Gefühl Verlust aufgefallen in die rechten Beine?
Was ist mir aufgefallen?
Gefühl Verlust.
Ja, meinen Sie, dass ich das irgendwie so taub anfühle?
Ja, Taubheits.
Ja, so ein bisschen habe ich schon den Eindruck.
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, es kribbelt so ein bisschen.
Und ja, so ein bisschen taub ist es schon.
Aber Sie haben keine Lehmung, ja?
Nein, ich kann das schon bewegen.
Wie ist Ihr Gangbild? Ist das normal?
Ich sehe mich ja selber nicht.
Aber ich denke schon, dass ich vielleicht so ein klein bisschen das Bein schonle.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Na ja, also in meinem Alter wäre das ja ein Wunder, wenn ich überhaupt nichts hätte.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren so einen Alterszucker.
Und da nehme ich halt Metformin ein.
Und schon ewig lange habe ich hohen Blutdruck.
Wie viele Dosieren ist Metformin?
Das ist 850.
Da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und was war noch außer diesen Alterszucker?
Der Blutdruck ist natürlich ein bisschen zu hoch.
Ja, aber das ist ja fast bei allen alten Leuten.
Aber Sie nehmen Medikamente, oder nicht?
Ja, ja, da nehme ich Simvastatin.
Gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ach nee, das... Warten Sie mal.
Gegen den Bluthochdruck nehme ich...
Simvastatin.
Ja, das andere ist für das Cholesterin, für den Cholesterinwert.
Ja, genau.
Ja, dann nehme ich... Wie heißt denn das?
Das heißt Candesatan.
Ja, wie viele Dosen Candesatan benutzt Sie?
Und seit wann?
Ja, am Anfang habe ich Ramipril genommen.
Da bin ich aber nicht gut mit klargekommen.
Und das Candesatan, da nehme ich jetzt... Das sind 8...
Ich meine, da steht 8 drauf. 8 Milligramm oder Gramm oder was das ist.
Und da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Und seit wann haben Sie den Bluthochdruck?
Schon lange, schon lange. 20 Jahre schon.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen.
Ist Ihnen ein Hautausschlag aufgefallen?
Ein Hautausschlag?
Ja, so ein richtiger Hautausschlag ist das nicht.
Sondern die Haut ist halt so schuppig und...
Ja, schuppig, ja.
Also, sieht nicht schön aus, ja.
Ja, die Schuppen sind okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch die Fieber?
Fieber? Ich habe mir das nicht gemessen.
Auf die Idee wäre ich gar nicht gekommen.
Aber Herzrasen, Herzstöpeln, Sie haben keine Herzrasen, Herzstöpeln, ja?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also, ich hatte vor vielen, vielen Jahren mal Herzprobleme.
Und deswegen nehme ich auch Aspirin 100.
100? Seit wann?
Wie lange ist das her?
Vor 15 Jahren habe ich mal so eine Stent implantiert bekommen.
Stimmt.
Eine Stent oder zwei? Nur eine Stent?
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele da drin hocken, aber jedenfalls sind da irgendwelche Gefäße gestentet worden.
Okay, das war auch vor 15 Jahren.
Vor 15 Jahren, ja.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Aber das ist schon so ewig lange her.
Das ist über 70 Jahre her, keine Ahnung, was damals war.
Und dann, ja, irgendwie so kleine Operationen.
Da war mal was am Bein, was operiert worden ist, aber es ist schon auch alles sehr lange her.
Aber Sie haben vergessen, was war der Grund, die Sprein-Operation?
Ja, da hatte ich einen kleinen Unfall.
Da musste was genäht werden, also das war nur ein kleines Unfall.
Gab es keine, dieses Knochenbruch oder irgendwas?
Nein, gebrochen war da nie was.
Das war eine kleine Wundplatzwunde.
Das war auch in Kinderalter.
Ja, als Jugendlicher.
Irgendwo hängen geblieben oder so.
Nehmen Sie auch andere Medikamente ein, außer diese Medikamente?
Nee, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nichts.
Gegen den Zucker, gegen die Blutfette und das Blutdruckmittel.
Sie rauchen, ja?
Bitte?
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, also hin und wieder rauche ich nochmal, aber eigentlich habe ich das aufgegeben.
Wann haben Sie aufgehört?
Eigentlich in dem Augenblick, als ich meinen Laden aufgegeben habe.
Und zwar, ich habe viele Jahre als Gastwirt gearbeitet und dann ist meine Frau gestorben.
Dann habe ich noch ein paar Jahre weiter gemacht und dann habe ich mit der Kneipe aufgehört.
Das war mir dann alleine zu anstrengend.
Insgesamt, wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Jetzt muss ich rechnen, wie lange habe ich geraucht.
Durchschnittlich, wie viele Zigaretten?
Ich habe nicht so furchtbar viel geraucht.
Ich habe immer nur ein halbes Päckchen aus der Gesellschaft mit geraucht.
Aber nie so ganz viel.
Und wie viele Jahre ungefähr?
Ich bin ja schon das Knochen alt.
Also, was habe ich denn angefangen?
Mit 20 Jahren hat sich das so eingeschlichen, als ich dann auch ein bisschen Geld hatte und mir das auch leisten konnte.
Und dann habe ich bestimmt bis vor 10 Jahren geraucht.
Vor 20 Jahren?
30 Jahre habe ich bestimmt geraucht.
Genau, ich glaube gut.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Das heißt, dass ungefähr 44 Jahre Sie haben geraucht und halben Päckchen?
Ja, ungefähr so.
Ungefähr 44 Jahre?
Nehmen Sie Alkohol süßlich?
Ja, auch nicht mehr so viel.
Früher habe ich natürlich immer ganz gerne mal einen mitgetrunken in der Kneipe.
Aber ja, das habe ich eigentlich jetzt so ziemlich sein gelernt.
Hin und wieder treffe ich mich mal mit meinen Kumpels und dann trinken wir auch noch mal ein Schnäppchen.
Oder abends trinke ich auch wohl mal ein Bier.
Aber alleine schmeckt es eigentlich nicht so richtig.
So besonders anders.
So kann man sagen, ja.
Was trinken Sie besonders anders?
Ein Bier oder irgendwas?
Ja, ein Bier oder auch mal ein paar Schnäppchen.
Bier oder Schnäppchen.
Das ist eine rätnische Frage. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen auch?
Drogen? Ne, da hätten Sie mir den Laden ja gleich zugemacht.
Ne, ne, also mit Drogen habe ich nie was zu tun gehabt.
Okay, okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergie und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Alles Essen und Trinken, was ich will.
Ich habe also auch noch nie irgendwie gemerkt, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch reagiere.
Ne, also da bin ich ganz unentfänglich.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Meine Eltern, die sind schon beide nicht alt geworden.
Mein Vater hatte sehr, sehr frühen Herzinfarkt.
Deswegen war das dann eigentlich auch so ein bisschen ein Anlass, dass ich nach meiner Herzgeschichte da,
dass ich dann mit dem Rauchen aufgehört habe.
Wie alt war er?
Er ist also Mitte 60 gewesen. Also er ist wirklich nicht alt geworden.
60, ja?
Mitte 60, also ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, 64 oder so war er.
64. Und Mutter seitlich?
Ja, meine Mutter, die ist zwar ein bisschen älter geworden, aber eigentlich war das auch tragisch.
Die hatte ganz was Doofes, die hatte eine Lungenembolie und ist da dran gestorben.
Da war sie 75 Jahre, also so alt wie ich jetzt ungefähr.
Hat sie eine chronische Erkrankung gehabt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Möglicherweise.
Irgendwas, aber man hat uns damals gesagt, dass sie an einer Lungenembolie gestorben ist.
Ja, meine herzlichen Damen und Herren, sie haben früh verloren, ihre Eltern.
Na gut, meine Eltern, das ist ja schon lange her.
Haben Sie auch keine Schwester?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind, ich habe den Laden von den Eltern übernommen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Verwittelt, verwittelt.
Sie haben schon erzählt, Entschuldigung.
Sind Sie wahrscheinlich Verhältnis? Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ja, ich war Gastwirt. Ich hatte eine Kneipe, so ein Lokal, wo man sich getroffen hat.
Wo man Bier getrunken hat und geraucht hat und Schnaps getrunken hat.
Da haben wir auch Feste gefeiert und wo die Männer abends nach Feierabend sich getroffen haben oder so.
Oder zum Kartenspielen.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Nein, wir waren kinderlos.
Kindernos. Waren Sie im letzten sechs Monate im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nee, das kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also diese Corona-Impfung seinerzeit, die habe ich natürlich alle tapfer machen lassen.
Das hat man ja gesagt, alte Leute sollten das tun.
Und ja, ich gehe auch, wenn ich daran denke und wenn es gerade so passt, gehe ich auch zur Grippe-Impfung hin.
Ja, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, wann ich geimpft worden bin.
Ich habe einige Fragen vergessen.
Haben Sie morgen Steifigkeit oder irgendwas?
Wer soll steif sein?
Morgen Steifigkeit.
Ich meine Anlassschmerzen.
Wenn Sie von dem Bett aufgestanden sind, haben Sie auch Anlassschmerzen oder Morgensteifigkeit oder Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, mein Rücken tut mir tatsächlich immer weh, weil ich früher so viel gestanden bin.
Oder Fingerschmerzen, allgemein Fingern und Gelenkeschmerzen.
Ja, dicke müde Knochen habe ich schon immer, aber solche Schmerzen wie jetzt mit dem Bein habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Treiben Sie nicht regelmäßig Sport?
So sehe ich glaube ich wirklich nicht aus, nein.
Also das habe ich nie gerne gemacht, Sport.
Als Jugendlicher vielleicht mal so ein bisschen was, aber was man so in der Schule machen musste, da haben wir auch mal Fußball gespielt.
Aber dass ich jetzt ein großer Sportler wäre, kann ich wirklich nicht sagen.
Ok.
In Leszys eine Woche hatten Sie eine Fernreise gemacht?
Ich meinte eine Bus- oder Flugfernreise?
Nein, ich habe keine langen Reisen, ich war immer nur zu Hause.
Ich habe einen Hund und da kann ich gar nicht so viel weg wissen.
Danke Herr Schneider.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich will jetzt natürlich wissen, woher die Schmerzen kommen und was man dagegen machen kann.
Das hoffe ich ja, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Ja eigentlich meinerseits habe ich einige verdacht, aber ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine Schaufensterkrankheit.
Das klingt ja interessant.
Ja, das ist eine langsame aufgetretene Krankheit.
Es geht immer langsamer und schlechter und schlimmer.
Einige Sachen, wie Sie sagen, dass die Hautveränderungen oder Halferlust oder Kripplergefühle bestätigen diese Krankheit.
Im medizinischen Bereich sagen wir auch auf K.
Wir müssen sofort den Puls prüfen.
Wie war der Puls? Ich habe gesagt, das ist der Beinpuls.
Und sofort die Ultraschall, die Doppler-Ultraschall.
Tut das weh?
Nein, die Ultraschall ist komplett schmerzfrei.
Und das dauert in den maximal drei oder fünf Minuten.
Das geht so schnell, das ist ja gut.
Wir machen alles hier. Sie warten nicht so viel.
Ich werde auch Blut abnehmen von Ihnen.
Und ich werde auch diese Doppler-Ultraschall führen.
Und Sie werden nicht so weit hier bleiben.
Ich muss nicht lange da bleiben?
Ja, ich hoffe.
Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Okay, gut. Ja, ich muss auch wieder zurück zu meinem Hund. Der wartet auf mich.
Genau, Sie vermissen sich.
Okay, möchte ich jemanden von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen stellen?
Welches Bein wurde operiert, rechts oder links?
Das ist so lange her, das war eine kleine Fleischrunde.
Das war am linken Bein.
Also strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Wo die Schmerzen ausstrahlen?
Nein, eigentlich sind die überwiegend im Unterschenkel.
Aber in den letzten Tagen haben sie bis in den Oberschenkel gereicht.
Also gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt auslaufen?
Hochlagerung oder so?
Stehen bleiben hilft.
In der Nacht ist es so, dass ich, wenn die Schmerzen zu arg sind,
dass ich dann tatsächlich mich hinsetzen muss und ein bisschen aufstehe und hin und herlaufe.
Dann geht es auch wieder besser.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen bis lang?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht getraut, noch mehr Schmerzmittel zu nehmen.
Ich nehme ja sowieso das Aspirin 100.
Ich weiß, dass das gegen Schmerzen nicht so viel ist.
Aber da soll man ja auch nicht so viel davon nehmen.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt nichts weiter genommen.
Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie Herzschlupf?
Ja, also mein Herz schlupft eigentlich inzwischen ganz normal.
Hat der Kollege aber auch gefragt, oder?
Ja, haben Sie Fieber?
Hat er auch gefragt, habe ich auch verneint.
Also ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig.
Ja, okay, danke.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Darf ich mal einen neuen Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, genau.
Friedrich Schneider ist 74 Jahre alt, 1,76 Meter groß,
wiegt aktuell 89 Kilogramm.
Er stärke sich mit seit einem Jahr bestehenden, progretenden Schmerzen im rechten Bein vor.
Okay.
Normalerweise hat er Schmerzen seit einem Jahr,
aber trotzdem hat er einen heftigen Schmerzen beim letzten Mal
nach dem 1 Meter Laufen.
Nach einem Meter?
100 Meter, Entschuldigung.
Er brauchte Pause machen.
Er brauchte Pause machen, ja?
Ja, er brauchte Pause machen.
Er leidet unter Wadenkrampf vor allem beim Laufen, auch nachts.
Schmerzen war früher Oberschenkel und gerade ist unter Schenkel auch Strahl.
Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzskala bei sieben von Zehen.
Der rechte Beinhaut ist schrubig geworden.
Die Haut des rechten Beines.
Ja, genau. Die Haut des rechten Beines.
Die Haut des rechten Beines ist schrubig geworden.
Haarverlust auch berichtet.
Und er klagte über auch Parasthesie und Haarverlust.
Er klagte über auch Parasthesie und Haarverlust.
Was war noch?
Und die Fragen nach Tachikardie, Dyspne, Hypoesthesie, Fieber und Ödeme und Fieber wurden verleint.
Als Vorerkrankungen erberichtet, seit Zehn Jahren leidet er an Diabetiktyp Siwae, behandelt mit Metformin 850 mg.
Seit Zehn Jahren, seit den Zehn Jahren Arterielipertonie, früher behandelt mit Ramipirir.
Er hat Ramipirir abgesetzt und behandelt weiter mit Candesartan 8 mg. Einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Er leidet auch an Hypercholesteremin behandelt mit Zymvastatin.
Die Dosisung habe ich vergessen.
Bei mir ist es unbekannt. Entschuldigung.
Ja, vergessen. Ich werde nochmal nachfragen.
Vor fünf Jahren musste eine Implantate operieren.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde eine Implantate operiert.
Seitdem nimmt er ein Assetto System.
Wo wurde eine Implantate operiert?
Es muss ein Herz sein. Entschuldigung.
Ja, genau. Sie sind recht.
Das war Beinode.
Richtig. Ich dachte anfangs, dass es ein Herz im Ständen war.
Er behandelt mit ASS 100 mg.
Als Kindheit war eine Translektomie.
In der Kindheit oder als Kind?
Als Kind. Okay.
Als Kind oder in der Kindheit? Eins von beiden.
Okay. In der Kindheit.
In der Kindheit wurde eine Translektomie durchgeführt.
Auch wegen eines Unfalls, einer kleinen Platzwunde, musste genäht werden.
Nach zehn Jahren hat das Rauchen aufgehört.
Insgesamt 22 Jahre.
Es besteht ein Rauch, eine Messe, 22 Jahre alt.
22 Packungsjahre.
20 Packungsjahre.
20 Packungsjahre hat es vor zehn Jahren aufgehört.
Okay.
Der Alkoholkonsum war besonders.
Er wurde verneint.
Er wurde verneint wegen allergieunterdrückter.
Vater ist an Myokartinfarkt.
Entschuldigung, Vater ist im Alter von 64 Jahren an Myokartinfarkt verstorben.
Mutter ist im Alter von 75 Jahren alt, Lungenembolie, verstorben.
Er ist Einzelkind.
Er ist verwitwet.
Er ist aktuell Retner.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Reiseanalyse unaufwendig.
Impfung ist vollständig.
Und das war alles.
Entschuldigung.
Ich musste fragen, Sie haben das Stände gesehen.
Aber ich musste fragen, wo war das Stände?
Das war Stände auch Gehirnsein an Interventionen der Radiologen.
Aber am Anfang dachte ich, dass nur Herz ...
Das ist ja auch richtig. Hat er auch gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er hatte Herzprobleme.
Genau.
Und da ist er mit einem Stände versorgt worden.
Und da haben Sie ja noch gefragt, ein oder zwei Stände.
Und da hatte er keine Ahnung, was Sie da gemacht haben.
Aber seitdem geht es mir wieder besser.
Also das war ein Corona-Ständ.
Okay.
Genau.
Aufgrund dieser anämestischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf eine POVK.
Was könnte differenzial diagnostisch noch sein?
TvT kann sein.
Meistens Arteritis.
Einige Arteritis, wie eine Kawasaki oder einige Arteritis kann sein.
Okay. Und was kann noch sein?
Was kann noch sein?
Haben Sie noch eine Idee?
Ich habe noch gefragt, diese Leimgeschichte, eine Wande oder irgendwas.
Was haben Sie gefragt?
Ich meine jetzt, Blumen, Leime, die Sie sehen.
Sie waren im Ausland nicht.
Ach so, okay.
Sie waren unauffällig.
Genau.
Aus diesem Grund weniger.
Ach so, Leinborreliose, meint Sie.
Ja, Leinborreliose, ich meinte das.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben noch was anderes gefragt.
Sie haben noch was anderes gefragt.
Sie haben noch Morgensteifigkeit gefragt.
Ja, Sie haben noch Morgensteifigkeit.
Genau.
Also das wäre unter Umständen noch so eine Idee, dass der rheumatologische ein Problem hätte.
Eigentlich rheumatologische Krankheit und auch die Arteritis oder auch diese Immunkrankheit.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ja, diagnostisch muss ich sofort die Pulse kontrollieren.
Dorsalispedis Pulse oder Femoral Pulse oder Populiteal Arteris.
ATP und ATP.
Tibialis Posteriori und Dolan.
Tibialis Posteriori.
Und nur an den Beinen?
Nein, nur an beiden Beinen. Ich muss auch vergleichen.
Beide Beine gleichzeitig die Messe und tropische Zeichen.
Ich muss auch tropische Zeichen vergleichen.
Tropische Zeichen, ja.
Tropische Zeichen, ich meinte das.
Haarverlust oder Schupinkie.
Sie hat Schupinkie.
Friedrich ist ein Mann.
Er hat eine Schupinkie Haut.
Natürlich das Wichtigste ist die Dopplersonographie.
Ja, was machen Sie noch?
Was mache ich noch?
Sie meinen das mitgebende Verfahren oder Labor?
Erstmal Labor und vielleicht noch körperliche Untersuchung.
Was könnte sein?
Körperliche Untersuchung, Hormonszeichen oder andere Zeichen.
Zum TVT-Auschluss, ja.
TVT, Hormonszeichen.
Was wäre vielleicht noch interessant?
Er hat ja von Kribbelpharazizin gesprochen.
Ich muss auch diese neurologische Zähnereflexe überpüfen.
Also neurologische Kontrolle auf alle Fälle.
Gut, ja. Und dann sind wir schon beim Labor. Was würden Sie bestimmen?
Ja, der Dimmel ist wichtig.
Auf alle Fälle, ja, genau. Was ist noch wichtig?
Prokaltzitonik kann sein.
Pro-BNP kann sein.
Auch wie eine Rechherzinfemie oder irgendwas.
Was war noch?
Auch die Entzündungsparameter oder Nierenparameter.
Natürlich auch die Lebeparameter.
Entzündungsparameter, ja.
Gut, dann haben wir die Duplex-Sonographie.
Haben Sie schon gesagt.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Duplex-Sonographie?
Verenglückte Gefäße und Verminderung.
Auf welcher Etage?
Es muss 2B oder 3.
Entschuldigung, es muss 3.
Was ist 3?
Was meinen Sie?
Ich meinte, dass es per VK.
VK-Stadium 3?
3, ja.
3 nicht.
Ich meinte eher, auf welcher Etage vermuten Sie den Verschluss?
Ah, am Ende.
Es ist 3.
Es muss 2B.
Ich habe vergessen eigentlich.
Nein, das ist ja das Stadium.
VK-Stadium.
Sprechen wir gleich darüber.
Jetzt wollte ich wissen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie machen die Duplex-Sonographie.
Da habe ich gesagt, was erwarten Sie?
Sie erwarten eine Verengung oder einen Verschluss.
Genau.
Auf welcher Ebene erwarten Sie den denn?
Oberschenkelebene oder Unterschenkelebene?
Genau, das ist richtig geschrieben.
Oberschenkel.
Nein, Unterschenkel.
Unterschenkel.
Er beschreibt eine Claudikation im Unterschenkel.
Das ist jetzt akut.
Aber nach oben gehen.
Möglicherweise hat er schon latent einen Verschluss.
Eine Verengung gehabt in der Unterschenkelebene.
Möglicherweise einen akuten Verschluss im Oberschenkel.
Muss man gucken.
Aber das Stadium ist B2 oder?
2B.
Ja, lassen Sie uns gucken.
Was ist Stadium 1?
Stadium 1 ist keine Beschwerden.
Keine Beschwerden. Stadium 2.
Keine Beschwerden.
Nach dem langen Reisen kann es langsam passieren.
Oder nicht häufig.
Stadium 2A ist mehr als 100 Meter.
Mehr als 100 Meter.
Ich meine sogar mehr als 200 Meter.
Entschuldigung, 200 Meter.
Und dann kommen wir zum Stadium 2B.
2B ist 200 Meter.
Wenn es weniger ist, genau.
Was ist denn PHAVK Stadium 3?
Das ist ulzerose oder total verschrusses Zeichen.
In Ruhe beschweren.
Ruhe Schmerz.
Auch spontan Wunden oder irgendwas.
Das ist Stadium 4.
Stadium 4 ist nekrosen Wunden, offene Stellen, Pieperpup.
Entschuldigung, ich habe ein Durcheinander.
Heute ist einiges durcheinander.
Wir spielen unsere Anamnese schnell noch zu Ende.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie für Ergebnisse rausbekommen.
Vor allen Dingen erstmal, was die Fußpose bringen.
Da kann man ja noch eine bestimmte Sache machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihnen das was sagt.
Knöchelarmindex.
Das hat gleich Blutdruck an den Knöcheln.
Knöcheln und Blutdruck am Arm.
Ob da eine große Differenz ist.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so etwas, was man bestimmen könnte.
Dann muss man natürlich gucken, was die PHAVK Sonographie gibt.
Was wäre denn das nächste bildgebende Verfahren?
Angiographie.
Genau, die Angiographie.
Das werden wir ja nicht heute und morgen machen.
Jetzt gucken wir erstmal nach den Befunden von heute.
Dann können wir uns den Patienten noch mal zusammen angucken.
Herr Dr. Toprak, heute ging es ein bisschen durcheinandersprachlich.
Wir haben immer noch das Z, was Ihnen große Schwierigkeiten macht.
Und was manchmal wirklich mich rätseln lässt, wovon Sie sprechen.
Sie verwaschen die Sprache so ein bisschen.
Das führt dazu, dass man sie manchmal nicht gut verstehen kann.
Dann machen Sie manchmal auch witzige Wortkonstruktionen.
Ich habe verstanden, als Sie nach den Anlaufschmerzen gefragt haben,
habe ich Anlassschmerzen gehört.
Deswegen habe ich noch mal nachgefragt, was Sie meinen.
Ich glaube, Sie meinten den Anlaufschmerz morgens.
Das kennt aber der Patient nicht.
Der kennt den Begriff nicht.
Es heißt Anlaufschmerz und nicht Anlassschmerz.
Ein Anlass ist eine Begebenheit, ein Grund, weshalb man irgendwo hingeht.
Der Anlass für meinen Arztbesuch ist, dass ich Schmerzen habe.
Es heißt Anlaufschmerz.
Sie müssen den Patienten natürlich fragen,
wenn Sie morgens aufstehen, haben Sie das Gefühl,
dass die Beine noch gar nicht so richtig wollen,
dass Ihnen die Gelenke steif sind.
Wenn Sie nach Morgensteifigkeit fragen,
kann der vielleicht ganz andere Ideen haben.
Das war das eine.
Dann haben Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch
ein komisches Wort für die Progrediente verwendet.
Sie wollten, glaube ich, sagen Progrediente Schmerzen,
aber Sie haben irgendwas anderes gesagt.
Sie haben Progrente oder so gesagt.
Progrediente.
Also Voranschreiten aus dem Lateinischen.
Dann ist noch mal die Frage,
wo hat der Patient seine Schmerzen geschildert?
Wo tut es ihm weh?
Genau.
Wir haben vergessen.
Wir haben aber was gesagt.
Unterschenkel nicht.
Am Anfang hat er gesagt, der rechte Unterschenkel.
Der hat ihm die ganze Zeit wehgetan.
Jetzt seit drei Tagen, wo sich das verschlechtert hat,
tut ihm auch der Oberschenkel weh.
Im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie genau das Gegenteil gesagt.
Da haben Sie gesagt, ihm tut früher der Oberschenkel weh
und jetzt der Unterschenkel.
Also Vorsicht.
Dann, ja, das wäre eigentlich ein Begriff,
der unbedingt kommen muss.
Wie nennt man denn solche Art von Schmerzen?
Welche Art?
Diese Schmerzen, die kommen
und die sich wieder zurückbilden,
wenn man in Ruhe ist.
Wie heißt der Begriff?
Können Sie noch mal detaillieren?
Ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Wie nennt man diese Schmerz-Symptomatik,
dass man merkt, dass er nicht mehr weiterlaufen kann,
stehen bleiben muss und nachher wieder weitergehen kann.
Ah, Claudipatio Intermittens, das ist die Meinung.
Ja, das wäre ein Stichwort,
das im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch unbedingt fallen müsste.
Also der Patient stellt sich vor
mit progrienten Schmerzen
und er beschreibt eine klassische Claudipatio Intermittens.
Das müsste zwingend kommen.
Dann, ja, wieder und wieder und wieder immer das Gleiche.
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie
ein Problem mit Ihren Beingefäßen.
Aber nicht wahrscheinlich Sie haben.
Und das ist ein Problem mit Ihren Beingefäßen.
Das ist ein Problem mit Ihren Beingefäßen.
Und auch als Vorerkrankung berichtet er von.
Ich habe es mir heute extra aufgeschrieben.
Denken Sie daran, das Verb steht an zweiter Stelle.
Das ist einfach so im Deutschen.
Und wenn es da nicht steht, klingt es nicht richtig.
Man kann das mal verkehrt machen, aber nicht ständig.
Dann haben Sie wieder, eigentlich völlig ohne Einleitung, diese Familienanamnese erwähnt.
Sowohl bei den Fragen als auch beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie eigentlich gesagt,
ja, also das und das sind seine Beschwerden. Der Vater ist mit 65 am Herzen erfahrt gestorben,
die Mutter mit 75 an der Lungenembolie. Also die Familienanamnese des Patienten ergab,
das der Vater und die Mutter. Dann das haben wir. Ja, dann der Mensch ist selber 74 Jahre alt. Er
erzählt, dass die Eltern mit 75 und 65 gestorben sind. Das liegt also mindestens 25 bis 30 Jahre
zurück. Da ist es eigentlich nicht mehr angebracht, seinen Beileid auszusprechen. Das macht man nicht.
Also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, meine Frau ist letzte Woche gestorben, ja, okay, dann kann ich
sagen, oh mein herzliches Beileid. Aber ein so lang zurückliegender, ja auch irgendwo in der
Natur der Sache liegender Todesfall. Mir kontrolliert doch heute niemand mehr,
weil meine Mutter vor 15 Jahren gestorben ist. Das macht man einfach nicht. Es ist ja zu
erwarten, wenn ich selber über 70 bin, dass meine Mutter nicht immer noch lebt. Das ist
Licht in der Natur der Dinge. Alte Leute sterben irgendwann. Wenn ich jetzt sage, oh je,
oh je, wie gesagt, mein Ehepartner ist vor wenigen Monaten verstorben oder so. Das ist eine andere
Geschichte. Oder mein Bruder oder meine Schwester. Das ist ja näher dran. Aber wenn
bei einem alten Menschen das also lange zurückliegt, würde ich nie kondolieren,
würde ich nie sagen. Was habe ich noch? Ja, wichtig ist tatsächlich, beide Beine angucken,
Fußpose, Seitenvergleich nicht vergessen. Auch die tropischen Veränderungen, das haben sie
schön gesagt, die hat er ja geschildert. Ja, Noxen haben wir gehabt. Was man tatsächlich
auch mal so einfließen lassen kann, das ist, wenn man auf ausdrückliche Nachfrage hat der
Patientin aktuelle Herzbeschwerden, verneint. Also dass man sagt, ich habe danach gefragt,
aber er hat gesagt, da hat er im Augenblick keine Beschwerden. Das ist schon so ein bisschen
verbindlich. Sie haben, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig verstanden, was der vom Beruf gemacht
hat. Sie haben nicht so richtig gefragt danach. Er hatte eine Kneipe. Er hatte eine Kneipe. Ja,
ich weiß nicht. Wissen Sie, was eine Kneipe ist? Eine Kneipe ist ein Restaurant. Sie verkaufen
Alkohol oder irgendwas. Und irgendwas, ja. Aber überwiegend Alkohol tatsächlich. Ja,
und insofern ist er in diesem Dunstkreis praktisch alt geworden. Aber man kann nicht sagen,
er ist Rentner. Ja, aber das ist schon wichtig, dass er früher als Gastwirt gearbeitet hat.
Gastwirt. Ich konnte dieses Wort nicht verstehen. Gastwirt. Ah, Gastronomie, das ist die
Oberbranche. Gastwirt. Ja, also ich denke mal, wir haben immer noch Probleme mit ihrer Aussprache.
Man muss sehr, sehr gut hinhören. Man muss sehr, sehr gut hinhören, weil sie nicht besonders
artikulieren. Sie verwaschen die Wörter so ein bisschen. Ich kann das nicht nachmachen. Es
wäre eine schlechte Imitation. Ich kann das nicht gut machen. Aber hören Sie vielleicht noch mal
rein in die Aufnahme, dass Sie merken, dass sie... Ja, ich glaube, in der deutschen Sprache gibt es
ziemlich viele so harte Laute. Das hört man alles nicht. Sie machen das alles weich. Und ich
glaube aber, im türkischen gibt es auch viele. Also hart anklingende Laute gibt es doch durchaus.
Das ist doch eigentlich keine so weiche Sprache, sondern da gibt es es doch durchaus. Und das
hört man eben oft bei Ihnen nicht raus. Es ist alles so... Ja, es ist ein bisschen verwaschen.
Und damit ist es schwierig, sie immer zu verstehen und immer das Richtige rauszuhören. Wenn es
ganz schlimm war, habe ich nachgefragt. Ja, und ich habe auch hin und wieder ja gleich gesagt,
wenn irgendeine grammatikalische Geschichte gar nicht stimmte. Ja, irgendwie bin ich heute
Abend nicht so richtig zufrieden. Merken Sie, ne? Ja, ich auch. Weil wir es schon so oft gemacht
haben und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass wir so richtig einen Fortschritt erreichen, sondern
es ist eigentlich immer wieder dasselbe. Immer wieder dieselben Fehler. Und ich weiß nicht,
was wir dagegen tun können. Ja, eigentlich finde ich, fändlich ist schade, wenn Sie zur
Prüfung antreten und die sagen Ihnen, lieber Doktor, wir verstehen Sie nicht. Das wäre doof.
Ja, also müssen wir was dran tun, dass man Sie besser verstehen kann. Ich weiß nicht,
ob Sie eine Möglichkeit haben, sprechen Sie auf Ihr Handy und hören Sie es nachher ab. Machen
Sie eine Sprachnachricht auf Deutsch, natürlich nicht auf Türkisch. Machen Sie eine Sprachnachricht
an sich selber und hören Sie sie nachher ab. Ja, und registrieren Sie mal, wie ausgeprägt die
Artikulation ist. Oder hören Sie unsere Simulation an. Sie müssten eigentlich rauszuhören,
dass es da einen Unterschied gibt. Bei mir knallt das viel mehr. Ich mache ein scharfes Tö,
ich mache ein scharfes Kö. Und bei Ihnen ist alles ein bisschen abgeschwächt. Und man kann
Sie, man kann deshalb oftmals nicht genau verstehen, was Sie sagen. Und dazu kommt,
dass Sie eben tatsächlich von dieser Satzstellung her oftmals auch noch Fehler machen und so ein
paar Grammatikfehler schleichen sich ein. Aber alles zusammen ist ein bisschen viel. Entweder
schlechte Aussprache und alles andere richtig oder gute Aussprache, dann darf auch mal ein Fehler
da drin sein. Aber alles drei zusammen ist ein bisschen viel. Gut, und versuchen wir noch mal
Ihr Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch noch mal schön zu strukturieren, dass Sie wirklich im Geiste
Überschriften setzen. Bei der Frage nach der Familienanamnese hat der Patient das und das
gesagt. Und die Frage nach Vorerkrankungen ergab, was weiß ich, einen langjährigen Diabetes
Melitus Typ 2 seit zehn Jahren. Ach, da stimmt auch irgendwas nicht. Sie haben, glaube ich,
gesagt, der hohe Blutdruck seit zehn Jahren. Da hat er aber gesagt, seit 20 Jahren. Und der
Diabetes seit zehn Jahren. Also, dass man das ein bisschen mehr anmoderiert. Dass man nicht
einfach nur die Fakten untereinander stellt, sondern sagt, jetzt berichte ich über dieses
Thema, jetzt berichte ich über dieses Thema. Und auch beim Patienten würde ich auch sagen,
also erstmal eigentlich ja schön, dass Sie da, ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen
Daten, die muss ich mal eben abfragen. So. Und dann, was sind Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden? Und
dann kommen natürlich die Nachfragen. Die Nachfragen zu den aktuellen Beschwerden. Und dann
kann man vielleicht auch so ein bisschen moderieren, sagen, Ihren allgemeinen Gesundheits- oder
um Ihre Beschwerden richtig einzuschätzen, muss ich noch ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
Dann fragt man zum Beispiel nach Herzbeschwerden, Verdauung. Haben Sie nicht gefragt, ne?
Verdauung und Wasserlassen haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Aber da gab es eine besüglich mit dem Wasserlassen.
Er hat gesagt, dass er nachts auf die Toilette muss, ne?
Gibt es eine besüglich mit dieser Krankheit mit Verdauernproblemen?
Nein, aber das müssen Sie trotzdem immer fragen. Das ist ja das Schlimme. Sie müssen ja diese
ganzen anderen Schwachsinnfragen auch stellen. Ich meine, auch das Herzputt in der Gutjahr-
Herz und Gefäße hängen natürlich zusammen, klar. Aber Sie müssen ja diese ganzen Rahmenfragen,
die in Ihrem Kataloge drin sind, die müssen Sie ja trotzdem stellen. Und dann muss man
das halt ein bisschen erklären. Der guten Ordnung halber muss ich auch noch danach fragen.
Auch das ist so was. Sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch nicht erwähnt,
schmerzbedingte Insomnie. Dass der also nachts aufwacht, weil sein Bein nicht gut
durchblutet ist und wenn er dann rumläuft, wird es wieder besser. Das hat er Ihnen erzählt,
aber das ist unter den Tisch gefallen. Gut, also nochmal ein bisschen Struktur in Ihren
Fragebogen. Ein bisschen eine Anmoderation. Jetzt kommt ein neues Thema. Jetzt habe ich über
Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden gefragt. Jetzt frage ich noch nach Ihren Vorerkrankungen.
Ist bei Ihnen was bekannt? Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie? Wie ist denn generell,
wie sind Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten? Da frage ich dann nach den Noxen. Da kann man dann auch
fragen, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport? Gut, das gehört eigentlich, finde ich auch immer ganz
gut zu den Lebensgewohnheiten dazu. Dann kommt natürlich die Frage nach dem Umfeld. Sie werden
sich vielleicht wundern, aber das ist für uns auch wichtig. Die Frage, ob es in Ihrer
Familie irgendwelche Krankheiten gab. Ihre Eltern leben vermutlich nicht mehr, kann ich schon bei
jemandem mit 74 sagen. Waren da irgendwelche Erkrankungen bekannt? Man kann das ein bisschen
verpacken, damit es nicht so abrupt ist. Praktisch die entsprechenden Überleitungen können Sie
dann als Arztgespräch verwenden. Natürlich wissen die Kollegen, was sie alles abgefragt
haben und worüber sie berichten werden. Sie müssen da also nicht so weit ausholen. Aber
immerhin kann man schon sagen, in der Familienanamnese ergab sich oder bei der
vegetativen Anamnese gab der Patient oder erwähnte der Patient eine schmerzbedingte Insomnie,
insbesondere in den letzten Wochen. Ansonsten aber Nügtori ein bis zwei Mal, auch das raubt
ihm ein bisschen den Schlaf. Also ein bisschen mehr Moderation, damit das ein bisschen verbindlicher
wird. Gut, nehmen Sie hier bitte nicht krumm. Es ist gut gemeint, ich möchte nicht, dass Sie
in der Prüfung sitzen und dass Sie sie blöde angucken und sagen, nö, das wollen wir so nicht.
Arbeiten Sie daran, ich möchte, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung bestehen. Ich möchte, dass alle Ihre
Prüfung bestehen. Wir brauchen türkische Ärzte, ja wir brauchen sie alle und es gibt jetzt einen
neuen Trend. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das gehört haben. Zu meiner großen Überraschung, Herr Lindemann
ist jetzt unser neuer Gesundheitsminister. Er hat eine Initiative ergriffen, dass die
Dokumente von medizinischen Fachkräften besser oder schneller anerkannt werden. Vielleicht hilft
es ja für Sie alle, dass die Bürokratie in diesem Hinblick, in dieser Hinsicht ein bisschen
abgespeckt wird und dass Sie ein bisschen schneller zu Ihren Approbationen kommen.
Sprachkenntnisse sind aber das A und O, das wissen Sie alle. Wenn Sie sich nicht mit Ihren
Patienten und Ihren Kollegen einschlägig unterhalten können, können Sie nicht gut
arbeiten. Egal, ob mündlich oder schriftlich, heute wird alles dokumentiert. Sie müssen alles
irgendwo in den Computer schreiben und ich gebe zu, ich habe im Laufe meiner Tätigkeit
im Krankenhaus verheerende Kommentare im Computer gelesen, wo man sagt, was um Gottes Willen hat
der Mensch gemeint, was wollte er uns mit diesem Satz sagen, weil die Leute einfach nicht gut
Deutsch sprechen. Es ist das A und O, dass sie angemessen dokumentieren können, dass sie
angemessen kommunizieren können, sowohl mit Fachleuten als auch mit den Patienten. A und
O, die Patienten, das ist Ihre Kunsthaft. Und die müssen Sie verstehen und Sie müssen selber
auch verstehen, was die von Ihnen wollen. In diesem Sinne, wie gesagt, nehmen Sie es mir
bitte nicht übel. Wir sehen uns sehr gerne am nächsten Donnerstag. Einen Fall habe ich noch mit.
Ja, Gott sei Dank, ich bin nicht übel. Halt die Ohren steif. Es kann nur besser werden.
Einen schönen Abend für heute. Wir sehen uns sehr gerne übermorgen. Ich hoffe,
dass nichts dazwischenkommt. Ich bin mit den beiden großen Kindern alleine am Donnerstag
und hoffe, dass sie beide um neun Uhr schlafen. Wenn es ganz dicke kommt, muss ich zwischendurch
kurz verschwinden, aber ich hoffe, dass das nicht passieren wird. Ansonsten habe ich hier
zwei kleine blonde Mädchen sitzen, die mitmachen. Für heute einen schönen Abend. Danke allen
fürs Mitmachen, fürs Mitdenken. Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag. Tschüss. Tschüss, vielen Dank.